each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
I knew him was recently as the president
and CEO of the american medical
informatics association amia he's now
the immediate past president and he's
perished chairman of the institute of
medicine's board on health care services
the National Committee on vital vital
and health statistics and the Board of
Regents of the National Library of
Medicine he's been involved in many
studies and reports some of which have
done some foundational work in
evaluating and understanding the role of
electronic medical records the topic
topics that he's been engaged in and has
a deep experience in over the years our
topics at the forefront of the minds of
our policy makers these days as well as
researchers in academic health care
today he'll be talking about personal
health information among competing
public goods can american public policy
find a better balance between individual
freedom health privacy and research
great great title instead of topics done
thank you very and a kind introduction
and it's a really a pleasure and I I'd
say the honor to be here I'm sorry I
have been here sooner because I have had
a terrific conversations with a lot of
people obviously related to microsoft
over the years Eric and I were actually
panelist together on a Diane Rehm Show a
few months ago with Jonathan Winer
talking about personal health records
and court Kristen toll has been a
colleague is related to a Mia so it's
not like I haven't had some interfaces I
sent Eric some actually set of topics
that I'd be happy to talk about but I
thought that this one might in fact in
light of I think really the importance
of Microsoft plays globally as well as
nationally and also at the policy level
might be a really a good topic so i hope
that it won't seem a little too arcane
it's kind of a 30,000 20,000 feet talk
on the other hand believe me if
been into relating to privacy policy
it's a contact sport much like
implementing a computer-based order
entry or any other kind of informatics
tour de force so at any rate I will
start by saying a few words about Amy I
don't know how many of you are familiar
with Amy of the american medical
informatics association but i want to
talk a little bit about them we've been
involved a mia in this issue of public
policy and also national health
information infrastructure kinds of
discussions for at least 13 15 years in
Washington and actually a frequently
called upon by staffers because we're
seeing really a sort of a neutral player
we a me as 4,000 implementations from 53
countries so it's pretty global as well
I will talk about the current state of
privacy policy and also attitudes
relating to it it's obviously all these
things could be an entire semester
course so I'm going to be truncating
this flood I do want to talk just very
briefly about the history of some of
these thinking's this thought because
actually things are changing we often
think that things don't change but
things do change and then I want to talk
about the current status where we are
and era that just law just passed
actually it has some interesting issues
that are still going to be being sort
out sorted out over the next number of
months and years and then what I really
want to do is hopefully make this
somewhat controversial and stimulating
to talk about how might we nudge
essentially a better balance being among
these competing social goods because I
think right at the present in our
country in particular we really do not
have in my view a healthy balance and I
think the Franklin matter is that to my
way of thinking is not ideal and maybe
if we can talk enough about this we
might be able to ship the drift so Amy
is an authority regarding the sound
application of health oriented
information and communication technology
I enjoy talking to Bill
crown says today about both of us are
interested in the CT side of this is the
IT side of it I think that's where a lot
of the future needs to go and then
related issues but we also are leaders
in informatics education and policy and
research we have a lot of meetings our
journal is the most cited Jamie as most
cited journal in the field and I'd urge
you to look at the website at your
convenience we also have an american
college of medical informatics of people
who are thought leaders who have been
elected as an honorary kind of group to
to that what is it this is my own
definition it's still sort of an
emerging indoor sport it's a scientific
field that draws upon really information
sciences and related technology to
enhance the use its related to action
how do you use these things to do what
you're trying to accomplish so it's not
so much on the IT the CT is the tea but
it's more like the verbs how do you make
the nouns work so you get complete
sentences and get where you're trying to
go and whether it's health care or
research education management or policy
we see it as a very key issue going
forward we like to think that we're
amiable and formet itions we describe
ourselves as not am ia but a mia we aim
yet to please so I think the idea is
we're really interested in transforming
health as well as health care from both
personal health care and consumer
dimensions of health records and so
forth up to and including public health
and down to the molecular level and
translational bioinformatics and any
other thing that I think we've done over
the last five years is try to make the
transition of informatics from a what I
would call a serious advocaten or a
serious clubsport to a formally
recognized profession and I think we've
pretty much accomplished that we are
also very globally interested in and
were the kind of happy benefactors of a
planning grant from the Bill and Melinda
Gates Foundation to try to set up with
the international colleagues
a global strategy to try to improve
health outcomes and health status
internationally also through using
informatics and also again particularly
on the human capacity site training
education and better things so i won't
go through this alphabet soup of
organizations that we relate to but
happily I think excellent progress is
being made to start moving to to the
topic we're talking about Richard Norton
Smith who's well-known historians said
if presidents are governed by any law
besides the Constitution is the law of
unintended consequences the point is is
that I've had a lot of work in health
privacy over the years I won't go
through all this except it's like
20-some years of a fair amount of
engagement at the policy level on a
number of these things and and the fact
that matter is there's this quote I
don't know the source of it maybe some
of you do and you can enlighten me but
it's the two things you don't want to
watch being made or laws and sausages
yes sir baseball baseball sure husband
okay that's great people who respect
them because it's a great quote and I
think actually a these with respect to
those sources should not vote I've ever
be made right yeah no I mean it's it's
one of those things that would make you
probably most skeptical about a
democracy getting through a week anyway
I think the key thing about it is I mean
obviously you do have and I think
serious lawmakers or do want to create
good policy whether it's health or
energy or anything else but if you look
at health policy at least this is my own
personal list of the desired things that
you'd like to see come out of it you'd
like to have the capacity to better deal
with illnesses and among loved ones and
family members you'd like to build
altruism and a better sense of community
you'd like to have better patient health
professional relationships it's a good
idea obviously you do want to improve
healthcare privacy and security it's a
desired thing improve health outcomes
and also health itself care through
evidence-based medicine and
actively engaging patients and
caregivers so that in fact they they are
part of the team if you will in every
sense of the word I think you'd like to
enhance personal choice on important
health matters yes hmm priorities garden
no they're not they're not they're just
a basket and in fact that's what we're
talking about is these are all goods and
then to some extent in terms of public
policy are in competition so it's not
like there is an answer but I will
you're anticipating a couple of my
slides in a minute and obviously you
would like to have both healthy
individuals as well as healthy healthy
society and ideally you'd like to have
trust built in society pardon pretty
fundamental difference somewhat related
yeah exactly in fact actually earlier
Eric and I Eric and I were talking about
something that both of us least in my
roots I'd worked at Wisconsin in multi
attribute le modeling and I'm sort of
puzzled somewhat that policy makers
aren't using it more I think it's really
quite robust and so in fact these are
sort of just a basket at the moment but
they could be weighted and they could be
ordered obviously to a specific
challenge but we've not really done that
as a matter of public policy and as far
as I know you know Gao doesn't do that
either or any group that's looking at
these things now the challenge of course
and Cheryl's Chandler's the colleague in
the UK that in the past it's you know
healthcare didn't matter a lot you could
hurt somebody but you wouldn't
necessarily help a lot but the problem
nowadays you know it used to be simple
in effective and relatively safe now
it's complex effective and potentially
dangerous and so you your your potential
downside as well as a much higher rosier
potential upside share but you
increasingly need to know what you're
doing and if that was true in the past
this is a slight bill stead from an
institute of medicine talk a couple
years ago you know as we move from
organs and systems and clinical
cognitive capacity being what it is
where we made decisions by clinical
phenotype to moving increasingly to
molecular medicine our capacity to do
any of these things
without computer assistance is just
quickly becoming obviously beyond the
usual you know way of practice sort of
memory based care the thing is now to
shift a little bit to to privacy and
health historically for about 2,000
years plus health has been considered
both an intrinsic good as well as a
instrumental good in other words there
are times where it's competing
instrumentally useful to be healthy you
can climb a mountain if you're healthy
but it's also a good thing to just be
healthy privacy has been considered
historically by most philosophers isn't
instrumental good and in the Hippocratic
tradition as well as the oath does speak
to confidentiality of patient
information among non professionals but
actually the professional had an
obligation to try to seek care for the
patient and share information if he
thought that or she thought that the
other person would actually the other
professional could help that patient and
you couldn't similarly part of this in
the context of do no harm you had an
obligation to improve the art if you
will so essentially research was
considered a piece of this and
oftentimes as prognostically so you know
what case not to take if the patient
wasn't going to get better but clearly
it was looking at knowledge and looking
at researches as an issue so in the
context of do no harm it's not like
you're not going to do something you
don't want to hurt the patient in the
process of trying to help them so it is
an action issue and research is key and
if you look at the early days of this
country you can't be from the University
of Virginia without a Jefferson quote
and so this is my obligatory Jefferson
quote you may not agree with this but
this is what he said without health
there can be no happiness and attention
to health and should come before all
other objects if you're from the
Northeast Ralph Waldo Emerson said the
first wealth is health now I stand in
front of you as a health professional so
there you are obviously that's my way of
getting out of bed than once as
physicians isn't
interesting that I think most people
never think much about their health
until they don't have it well it is true
that you know again if you look at
weights what you put on on these weights
if it's a nice sunny day and your
healthiest you put a different weight on
some of the values and these things
shift again how you would shift some of
those would shift perhaps depending on
your health status or other kinds of
stage but any rate the point is
historically at least health has been
considered really pretty important if
you look at the day what's actually
happening out in the real world Utah has
a law where patients can opt out from
their children's immunization records
being shared with other providers if the
kid comes into emergency room they can
download and find out whether so you
don't over immunize kids or also under
immunize kids parents can opt their
children out of it and the last is this
is probably about four years ago last I
checked but less than four percent of
patients parents do so ninety-six
ninety-seven percent something like that
actually stay in the system the flip
side of it because one of the things you
get into when you talk about these
things or opt-in opt-out mandatory
opnion out out there's a lot of ways you
can go at this in Massachusetts they
have a system where you have to opt-in
to having your data shared not in this
children as adults and I think if I
think John lamb good last time I talked
to him said that I think that is
something like 44 or not over ninety six
percent do opt in to have their data
shared so the point is if you look at
places where people have to actually
decide and do decide somewhere around
nineteen eighty-five percent of people
are pretty interested in seeing
well it is secure it's generally secure
data but the point is I think the fact
is they're trusting at the margin that
the system will in fact will look after
yeah we get to explain anything more
exactly what that means in Massachusetts
when they share does that mean they stay
they share the other data who they are
their identity to anybody who is
interested in looking no no this is
among this is among if you go from one
emergency room to a clinic or something
these are official providers yeah
patient okay and and the data are
obviously protected secured on the other
hand the clinician does get the data set
of Harvard based clinician wanted to do
a study goody work with this is date
they were that's part of what my talk is
about okay in other words they don't
have blanket uses to be able to use it
now if you some of the argument that's
gotten into the issue of privacy and and
patient data is the issue of trust and
that the feeling that if you if you're
not very careful about privacy
considerations its its erosive to trust
of course that's difficult to quantity
but one of the things that I think is
interesting David mechanic very
distinguished professor of medical
sociology at Rutgers and co researchers
have actually studied desk and I think
again what sort of fascinating when they
just go to patients and ask them what
are the factors that are important in in
trust in your care the top one that
comes out of that is does the person can
I relate to this person does a clinician
actually somebody actually I I can even
connect with and often times that takes
a little time but the point is is this
somebody that that you know really
listens and really here's what I'm
trying to talk about and really meets me
there next to that and fairly close to
that is do they seem to know what
they're talking about be confident which
obviously is is quite important as well
and technical competence is a high
priority oftentimes though that's not
that well
study is kind of like well do they
appear to be up to date on research or
other kinds of things it's not like this
is a very sophisticated approach a lot
of patients take to this the third thing
that's important is do they advocate for
me if I need to talk to an insurer to
get some help or something well they
kind of go in my corn in my corner and
fight for me for things they think are
important for me and if it even comes up
at all confidentiality is just generally
assume and it rarely even came up as an
explicit issue so it's magic much and
much mentioned much less frequently than
again oftentimes the conversations about
this would tend to lead you to believe
it is interesting on the relative issue
of trust and electronic health records
that at least anecdotal evidence from a
lot of these places that do have secure
websites where patients are able to
interact with their own data and even
have dialogue with their clinicians it
does seem to actually be quite important
relic to the sense of trust so again
that's a space that I think isn't
necessarily separated if you will in the
electronic age it looks like some of
that in fact some of the communications
technologies it's not just information
it's really communication technology can
be really quite helpful to patients so
the question the point is that if you
look now though ship from some of those
things to say well where is it today
whereas privacy in this in contemporary
health policy privacy is very important
and how important i think is really what
we're talking about how important should
be in the relative mix of a variety of
social goods that you're trying to
balance again that's really the question
is it more important than quality safety
cost research social trust altruism or
should it balance in this kind of scale
why what other people talk of privacy
deprecating descend about
things that can have new privacy is not
respected and those are societal things
right underneath you were in Europe in
the 30s you will concerned about your
religious that speak nothing is that
determine where they live or die in
health care what is there any consensus
in the US on why is privacy what
consequences of lack of privacy well I
talked about then and some subsequent
slides and I'll get into it a little bit
but the problem of course using the word
privacy is there's not even a common
definition I mean confidentiality and
security you can kind of think of in
operational terms did somebody divulge
something I didn't want them to that's
breaking a confidence is the system not
secure that's something I can sort test
privacy is a broader and yes sir maybe a
tangential as the economy's recently
rolled up the u.s. section sex offender
sex offender register knows how many you
finish will be creative the government
rolls from all the existing medical
records down on the internet you ever
guess no
any rate this is it kind of interesting
i went to bing just as an interesting
kind of proxy of just throwing out words
and if you throw privacy on there and it
was 1.2 billion community 709 million
health 687 million health research 343
you can read them trust 157 you go down
to freedom freedom okay nine and by you
get to altruism you know it's just the
1.2 yeah well I'll leave that to you
folks just out it just as a footnote
against this sex outperforms privacy but
at any event love it incidentally does
it and death and taxes don't come close
so the point is just as a weird sort of
social proxy of at least what's
circulating out there in terms of terms
I think it's sort of fascinating the
point is it definitions to get it your
your question definitions of privacy are
not static and in fact as a matter of
law for for many years Brandeis had
really pretty much defined privacy and
American contacts from American American
law and I'm not a lawyer so so some of
these things I don't present to you as
as being something a legal scholar would
present to you but it was really defined
as a right to be left alone not be
bothered and in fact the fact that you
can call up a phone number and say i
don't want marketers calling me during
dinner is an example of the kind of the
right to be left alone sort of thing
while you're having dinner with your
family when current Supreme Court
justice was being vetted by the Senate
he described the privacy is actually
saying really maybe not the best word he
really saw it's more trying to get the
concept of freedom of conscience more
than privacy which frankly I think
personally I tend to resonate with just
that the personal level but any room on
the other hand I would say there are
some people on the more rigorous end of
the privacy that have been defined by
others as privacy fundamentalist would
say well I want to the right to remain
unknown not to be left alone but
actually remain unknown and and
somewhere among all of these things are
bubbling out there and I have another
slight in the middle to talk about it
but I do think it right now I'd say that
privacy in this country we really do
define it both as an instrumental and
insurance II good I think we have
crossed that boundary but again there's
not a way to really know this now
there's been a fair amount of
legislation over the years and it's kind
of fascinating that in fact in the 1970s
I think of a 76 but didn't take the time
to really look it up the u.s. past
actually a law that did if you were at
the in the Department of Defense as a
service member or in the VA you actually
did have your your personal health
information protected as a functional
law but because we don't have a national
health care system it didn't cover
everybody and it's fascinating because
the rest of the world that did have then
systems of care kind of passed the law
like the US law but we never got around
to it for doing everybody else and by
the time we started really trying to do
that as a function of federal law in
6760 96 97
for the other countries yeah oh yeah
absolutely we were clearly leading the
world and in a summary kind of ironic
sort of way are the study I chaired on
the computer based patient record 91 a
lot of countries went off right then and
the VA went off and did it as we know
the story on that and develop piston and
a month based thing that really then
moved the VA from having some of the
best worst performance experience to
some of the best of breed so it's kind
of fascinating that again the price
America has paid by not having if you
will and it's obviously we're debating
at the national level right now but I
think we you know clearly seen with a
vulcanized sort of approach to to care
that some of these things the u.s.
actually has led on but then necessarily
hasn't across the country benefited
totally from anyway so hit by one I'll
call HIPAA one was basically done as a
Privacy Rule it wasn't really mandated
in detail it was left for rulemaking
which is a very arcane kind of process
to to decide what that would look like
because the Congress couldn't come up
with a clear decision actually I had met
with Senator Bennet in on Arbor Day in
1995 and gave my little elevator speech
and he decided to to in fact sponsor
bill Senate 1330 which was actually a
confidentiality security bill that got
very close to passing the Senate and
might have in fact actually bypass that
but it failed just like a lot of other
things most things don't make it through
the our Juice approach so anyway went to
rulemaking and at that point I was
chairing the ncb HS the National
Committee on vital and health statistics
as Eric mentioned during the shillelagh
most went for Secretary shillelagh
during the Clinton administration when
we went through all the hearings we
heard from 75 76 people about what these
rules should look like and advised the
country on that so I sort of have some
scars from from obviously that process
because this is not something that
everybody is going to line up and agree
on that's just the way it is
by 2009 we passed what will essentially
qualify as a HIPAA to and and this time
we Congress did write some specific
kinds of things then also did say
there'd be real making on a number of
issues and the fact that matter is I
think that it's going to be a little bit
of a struggle to both see that care and
research issues can be in medical
research I can in fact move forward or
all kinds of Health Services Research
because of some of the ways this is
frame so part of the reason I'm talking
about this today is is this is dynamic
and it's not actually getting more
balanced if anything we're running a
risk I think of making it even more of a
problem of course the genetic privacy
law did pass and obviously one of the
reasons I think that this issue is a hot
issue in this country is where people
can lose health insurance because of
somebody finding out a prior condition
or something our absence of having a
nationally mandated universal access to
care clearly torques the privacy debate
as well as an awfully lot of issues you
don't that are out there that relate to
this so it's not thousand nine is
especially talking about research
interests and care actually that's part
of their shoes yeah actually in this
country we sort of are dealing with
privacy and research I mean excuse me
care and research as sort of the same
bag and that's not the way Europe the UK
Canada have approached it they've
actually approached it separately as
this is care policy and procedures and
regs and this is research and I think
frankly what's happened is is it's hard
to keep both of those balls in the air
because the care alone is so complicated
teresting hold out in discussion care
and research there are elements if you
have their elements and of course
obviously if it's a matter of public
health as you know there's private I
mean there's a set of law that says yes
you can get something too for h1n1 or
something like that you know the the
public good from that context on a
public health is not part of this but
clearly as part of the total picture now
if you look at the market segmentation
about
attitudes of privacy just to get to your
point question earlier comment actually
unchanged a huge amount at least from my
ability to try to look at polls of this
over the over the years since about
Harris akwa facts in 95 it may have
shifted some but the fact the matter is
about twenty percent of the people say
huh you know there are different ways of
saying huh but it's it's just not
something to think about or get
exercised about somewhere around half
are what you call privacy pragmatists as
their terminology which is that well
privacy as opposed to what I mean what
am i training off on this thing if it's
important enough I might be willing to
give quite a bit whereas on the other
hand if it's something trivial on hey
what are you talking about meanwhile a
problem that they define it as privacy
fundamental since meeting about twenty
five percent because I said when you
really get down to when people are faced
with the choice on the pragmatic side
it's probably closer to I don't know
five ten percent but but that seems the
way it seems to be playing out any rate
the point is that from those data people
had the highest confidence and that at
that time and I think this may be a
shift a little bit of data being used by
researchers as in fact being the highest
confidence next highest confidence with
dr. nurses hospital mistress so so
confidence in the use of it by insurers
and employers and in fact if you look at
air to our HIPAA to on the era
increasingly how other business
associates and such can use data seems
to be tightening down yes sir one pot
are they about the same yeah they were
pretty close no they're really quite
close and i think the hospital
administrators mostly where they were
using it to manage the system and they
were seen is actually part of if you
will the legitimate kind of care process
but if you look at the full spectrum
yeah let's listen listen argue
the general population had a pretty
sophisticated understanding Ephesians
yeah I would say well as general numbers
go but keep an eye on these are sampled
data and in it shifts up so it's not
again like get a this is really you know
science in a really robust point 0 0 0 3
standard deviations kind of thing but I
mean as such things go partner is it
statistically significant ah well I'm
not a social scientist in that guy you
need to have our Eric answer that for me
but at any rate I mean the number said
they have some confidence in it was put
it that way I can some of you know what
the definition of together with privacy
on average with your different cohorts
think that means office yeah you said
before even forget about health as long
as I heard healthy and i will just
expect similar stuff happens especially
the medical privacy well i mean that's
it there's just no question i mean i
just having practice surgery for 25
years you know i'm patient on one day
just as opposed to when they're both
their disease can affect their way
thinking too I mean let's face it it's
not like we're separate from from what
we are and do so there's a lot of
reasons why some of these things are
certainly mutable any rate if you look
at the full spectrum damn Macy's has his
comment that in every global village
you'll have a global village idiot and I
think part of the problem unfortunately
with some of the early days of computer
technology is that the Wild West idea of
everything ought to be free and open and
let anything go was I think part of why
there was some concerns about in fact
how responsible was this going to be as
sort of an industry as i said i never
saw a record I didn't enjoy you know
that kind of mindset and it's a total
other end of this well then you get the
privacy what are you talking about
privacy versus what I want to be left
alone I want to remain unknown and then
the purest was I want everybody to be
anonymous I mean there's actually some
folks who would just as soon have a
essentially
way off the scale anyway so the question
and I think where are we today and my
assertion and I'll present data that
would suggest where we are in this
current bake-off of social goods I would
say at the moment federal privacy
legislation and regulation is increasing
health care costs it is adding some
greater privacy protection but I'd say
even the privacy people don't think it's
adding enough and most the other folks
see where it could be improved and I
think actually a HIPAA to will era to
era will in fact tighten up some of
those things clearly irritate some
patients and citizens involving seeking
care signing forms and so forth it
worsens the quality care and safety and
I'll go through this while contributing
to a loss of medical privacy given a key
example of that it does it and I think
the best case can be made it impacts
negatively on the volume of all types of
biomedical and health research and at
the at the philosophical level there's
evidence and certainly scholars own or
O'Neill probably the most distinguished
who's written about that it actually
threatens community sharing and corrodes
social trust and sense of community one
survey at the time that HIPAA one was
coming through a study that the American
Hospital Association which you could say
is hardly a negative neutral bystander
did a public survey on an instrument
that showed that eighty-five percent of
people when this was coming in the
rulemaking felt that consent
requirements would inversely affect the
care of elderly because patient might
have a hard time understanding all of
this and might get scared and so forth
and would therefore share data to
frankly be in their interest time and
doctors offices would be spent with care
and not paper paper work instead of care
people felt like they'd be spending time
on this you can spend the money for
patient care and get a better ROI the
one I did review a paper for a journal
that didn't get accepted the paper
didn't get accepted but there's the only
thing i've seen that really tried to
cost this out but they'd costed out that
it added by their analysis at least a
dollar per visit or a dollar day /
hospitalization to deal with the HIPAA
requirements HIPAA one says it'll be a
hassle to sign the consent form before
every visit to a doctor hospital or
pharmacy so forth and sixty percent
didn't think it'd probably enhanced
their privacy so there is a reasonable
amount of skepticism actually going in
into this I think the point is though
does current privacy policy impact on
privacy safety and quality and the
argument I would make is that the fact
that we don't have a unique health
identifier in this country which almost
every developed economy does have is I
think both the problem with quality as
well as privacy and the way that works I
was on President Bush's interoperability
Commission the day we presented our
report happened to be the day we were
also having our national meeting at a
Mia and I think our five members of the
Commission who were on that panel and we
went from the Capitol where the report
was released to our meeting at the
hilton and had a panel about what was in
it and a woman during the discussion
period raised her hand she says I've got
a question I hope the Commission
addressed she says my name is Mary Smith
maybe you'll already guess where i'm
coming from she says but i'd love to
have the country allow me to have a
unique health identifier because mary
smith is not a really uncommon name in
the US and she says I don't want other
marasmus get my health information and
I'm absolutely sure I don't want my
record to have the wrong Mary Smith data
and then some doctor I'm coming tues
thinking is my data and do something to
me that is not sensible well that's
although again there's not a lot of
things to prove that that happens it's
hardly what you'd call a strange kind of
logic and I think the chance is that in
fact that is real is it's true now the
fact is people have said well you can do
all this authentication with algorithms
and you don't really need a unique
number but the fact that matter is you
do have a drop off if in fact you don't
have more identifiers that you can use
in that
algorithm and social security number for
example which when I was chairing NC BHS
supposedly an ant Lake County was the
toss of a coin because of so many people
that had counterfeited social security
numbers but if you go to other places I
guess in Indiana it gives you about a
fifteen percent I think better accuracy
if you have it in the algorithm well
shouldn't people be able to choose to
have a unique identifier that it would
reduce least for Mary Smith now if
you're I don't know a name that's highly
unusual that's probably less of an issue
but it still as I think a safety issue
as well as a quality issue so that I
think is actually is is not trivial and
there are a number a mia has been on
record for some years hadn't pushed it
because it's as you know this was part
of HIPAA was a unique provider plan and
personal health identifiers but the
partner yeah but it but it never went
anywhere because there was such an
uproar that Vice President Gore put a
kibosh on and that's been since
maintained and so even the option to be
able to do this is not something that
actually so we have a paternalistic view
in there that ops you toward privacy
kind of whether in fact you really
wanted to go that direction or not which
is part of my point of privacy pardon
oil is no privacy well the crime there
were enough from the privacy I'm a
privacy advocate I really feel like I am
in fact I went as I say I got thirteen
thirty even a bill sponsored at one
point so but I think if you're really
talking about the the more committed
whatever privacy community made such an
uproar about it in the New York Times
was it was a lot of fear got into the
mix of the thing and so they just said
we don't need that headache and so they
shut it him
well they got a lot of hanging on your
plate right now and in fact actually
that was stirring you know the Clinton
administration I just think they didn't
want to mess with so anyway so the
question in moving to research which
really has the most information yeah
well back to the marasmus program yeah
what happens if you'll se merece Miss
January first 99 1985 like the name and
birthday well again if you look across
the u.s. probably not just one Mary
Smith that was born that day or was the
birthday really recorder right and do
you have different ones of these so I
mean the point is that you know the
algorithms you probably still will
absolutely want to use in our room it's
good number together with well as I said
you you have these things all give you
an added additional accuracy but the
fact is if you can have another unique
number it does at the margin give you
even greater accuracy and write the
point I'm trying to make is it right now
our federal policy is not allowing us to
even call a number and say why don't you
use my passport number or my state
driver's license number as a unique
health identify it's fine for me okay
that's that's what I'm saying if that's
not an option right now and it has both
privacy implications you know as well as
health and safety implications okay
research this is probably where and if
being at Microsoft Research this is
probably where I think the best evidence
exists that it's a problem there have
been in the first instances the
association american medical colleges
and learning Hospital Association
American College of Cardiology America
Society of Clinical Oncology ncaab arc
Academy health there have been a number
of survey studies that have suggested
shown that that the HIPAA does impact
impact negatively on biomedical research
and health research across the board all
kinds of weather whatever researcher
you're engaged in and what kind of
whatever kind of research
you're doing that relates to person
specific information in seven two
thousand seven nine the Association
academic health centers but probably
most distinguished and influential
report just came out from the Institute
of Medicine but at least as the point is
no none of these studies have given
conflicting evidence that oh no it's not
so bad I'm on everybody is pretty much
in agreement that this is having an
impact and in fact there are some people
who feel like it's much easier nowadays
to do research in other countries
because of the costs generally or not
that you do certain kinds of studies and
by the time you have to do all this data
management as well it just becomes at
the margin something that's problematic
now the question is will the air at two
well era HIPAA to make this even worse
and I think there are a couple areas
there concerning some of us one it's
advocating use of minimum data sets and
and in fact changing the rules on when
data is anonymized and arguing to try to
move to to minimum data sets and it also
gives business associates it brings more
business associates into it and and
their penalties that if the data are
misused the business associate may pay
quite a penalty and in the UK when they
were going through this when I was over
there Cambridge and they sorted out but
the time they were again putting more
institutions to greater culpability and
the institutions were saying well why do
I want to go through a risk having more
problems come down on my head with if I
don't give data for research I'd saved
myself a potential exposure well that's
that's part of the rulemaking process so
that's you know you can go to the web
and check some of that out but the fact
that matter is research ask my people to
join best you can
not just note variable but in variables
that have work the business that you
need just doing these three variables
well and this is why I think that again
it depends on the kind of research
you're doing but again at the margin I
think it would make things more
problematic now there's a set of
timelines on this and I'm not going in
the interest of our time I'd like to
have some also time for open discussion
but there's a set of things that relate
to all of this and their arcane enough
but important enough that I think the
research community should really show at
the margin more interest in tracking
some of these things and at least today
I'm aware that they're necessarily doing
that's personal and you know I think
there is interest these things are being
traced well what did the iom say in
beyond the Privacy Rule they basically
were saying two things privacy isn't as
protective as needs to be with the
current way we're doing it but we also
are impacting negatively on research we
could probably build a better mousetrap
and the fact was that it said HIPAA
doesn't adequately protect privacy
security as well consistently as it
might I think arrow will actually help
some of some of that by broadening some
of the coverage but he also it doesn't
facilitate legitimate research a spatial
database and repository search and it's
fascinating that if you look at the era
it talked about comparative
effectiveness as a research and using
data repositories to look at comparative
effectiveness so it's kind of
fascinating there's a discordant tension
in there which was part of the reasons
why I thought it might become an
interesting talk to try to summarize her
maybe we are on this is that even
Congress sort of seems to sense to
recognize that they want two things but
they aren't necessarily managing to them
simultaneously yes it is laughlin to
illustrate that security and privacy
stopping
despite one well I think most of the
question was what's the evidence that we
got that bigger problem if you will I
think a lot of it is is is you know the
occasional highly publicized situation
where a Veterans Administration computer
turns up in somebody's car or stolen and
something and our thousands of Social
Security so it says it's in fact it's
really fascinating if you look at keep
in mind that with Medicare since
nineteen sixty-five all health data on
everybody over 65 to in order to get
payment has been sent to the government
and how many breaches I mean you know
have you heard about so you know clearly
the performance at some level there's a
disconnect between I think the in some
instances the popular popular sense of
how serious is I think a lot of it
though is not that you know if you
really are sophisticated anchor it's
really tough to you know protect all
this you guys experts at that so it's
not as though in fact you can run but in
that it is kind of hard to hide so the
other issue though is where is it so
it's both a science issue but it's also
perception issue a to and and obviously
you live off the perception issue yeah
bad case in Britain yeah we go to the
stage where the word unencrypted appears
in the general journalist in literature
well I say I mean I think the fact is
there are problems and I don't think
that we're you know realistic to be
standing here saying that there won't be
some problems problems it is an issue
these are competing goods they are good
and they're in competition I think
that's issue you were not you're not
going to come up with obviously an ideal
circumstance situation
partly financial investor Thank You
cliff data take them placed in value
data as they develop breasts and then
manager all right so it's an example
we're talking very high quality very
high value information you learn to deal
with it well yeah in it you know we have
a for additional financing system i can
go use an ATM machine in italy or
wherever and traveling somehow it seems
to basically fly yet I would have every
single privacy document ergotron
financial institution says we will not
disclose except as required or permitted
by law yeah and in fact they can do with
a dime piece well I mean this is a part
of the other issue because for payment
and quality and all these sorts of
things there are a large number players
again in our kind of system that will
see see your information and and believe
me fraud and abuse is not a trivial
consideration I mean the president the
other night was saying well we could
probably pay for most of our health care
problems if we just clean this up so and
and it's not totally off the mark there
in front of abuse in this space is
really huge anyway the IOM said that
really the HHS should really develop a
new approach and it really should favor
de-identified data sets and it's
interesting that as I said limited data
sets is included in ARR it's not clear
how that will come out but at the end of
the thing they're saying that HIPAA
should just exempt all research from
HIPAA rule it's enough of a social good
that we don't want to pay that much of a
social price we need to protect it
better where we can should but we ought
to manage to this is research as
something that is obviously important I
think taking the sense that G at the
start of the genomic area such there
might be some things that could really
improve patient health so if it didn't
matter I guess you wouldn't see if
researchers didn't matter so what but
increasingly I think it does and as I
made this comment earlier the fact is
the US has taken a different approach to
this and then Europe and Canada yes sir
you said emphasize the identified data
you start talking about genomic
information it's really hard to get
de-identified data at that point time
yeah you you're not just whistling in
fact Russell who's professor of
translational bioinformatics and
computer science and health and
everything else at Stanford gives an
annual science of the Year presentation
at our translational bioinformatics
meeting and in March 15 he talked about
how tough it is to actually if you will
anonymize your your genomic data you
have to there's a lot of fingerprints on
a lot of snips and if you really want to
to deal with that that that's not a
trivial task as you as you pointed out
and I think there was a general a
surprise from some of this more recent
research it's a little tougher to do
than in fact people were even thinking
two years ago target that you're going
to still be in conflict where you can
tree well NS that will get to part of my
at least reason why I think we need to
think about not too d downside the
privacy but from the iom perspective
find more creative ways to also let
people in fact express themselves as
free citizens and a free nation to say
how they choose to use their data and
given some of the options to do that now
you know i say i said that i am not as a
citizen today the government does not
help me have a unique personal health
identifier okay mean why but they do it
can I do that on the side so if you look
at the personal genomic space right
saying 23mm ever so they're getting
genomic information
you can fill out their surveys yet so
there's definite yes but I'm talking as
a matter of government policy okay I
mean it's a free country you look like
people like me or faster cures or some
of these where people are giving all
their data and so it's no question okay
so the point is the other thing is true
about this if too many people opt out
the free rider problem comes up nobody
leaves the station so it's not like it's
simply a trivial matter that well just
let people totally kind of choose on the
other hand I say the evidence to date
would suggest that you would have cohort
sizes pretty darn large if you're up
around eighty ninety five percent that's
pretty good and so it looks like frankly
that you'd come out okay but we don't
give people as a government policy that
that opportunity yeah and we the courts
of eighty-five percent maybe enough to
skew the data badly the recent report on
HR GM breast cancer really dependent of
the fact that say one set of coral
voluntary the other was not and another
splinter oh no it's not a trivial issue
you're absolutely right in fact
Minnesota during the 80s Early 90s I
guess passed a law that you had to have
people's permission to use their data
for research Mayo Clinic had been in
operation 107 50 years they'd never had
a complaint from Olmsted County anybody
ever in their history and they had this
long well Mayo Clinic is not a trivial
institution in Minnesota and neither's
University of Minnesota and so the
legislature came back rethought that and
said well you got to make a reasonable
college try to reach them to get an
answer but if you can't get them you can
use their data and it turns out they
change the law in it and again it's sort
of things moving along but the
interesting thing was during that period
it was disproportionately young women
who were opting out so if you're talking
about breast cancel cancer in a young
cohort kind of breast cancer you sort of
make the decision for everybody so it's
it's not it's not a totally free kind of
thing and I think your point is is a
good one any rate I think it's also true
that many research projects absolutely
need to authenticate who they're dealing
with they're not interested in Don
Denver but they're interested in knowing
that it is this person and and so
sometimes you do need to definitely be
able to to know that and of course I
think airing some of your research has
has tried to deal with that but so many
things you can't answer and get some
pretty good data on but other kinds of
things would probably more robust if you
actually were able to to really know who
you're dealing with any wage effort
Madison I quoted Jefferson a little bit
another local to UVA in Virginia James
Madison he was a part of the original
founders his quote was a popular
government without popular information
or the means that were requiring
prologue to a forester tragedy knowledge
will forever govern ignorance and people
who mean to be their own governors must
arm themselves to the power which
knowledge gets I mean again we've had a
tradition this sort of says and if you
look at our census it goes back to
family in the country we've typically
really have I think sort of argued that
data and accurate data the best data we
can is really a social good and
something we should do I'm running a
little short of time I think the point
is I think some of us were not as strong
on the switch as we might have been when
we were going through this we were
focusing on it more from the privacy
side and security confidentiality side
and didn't really kind of have a more
robust thing I'm partly responsible i
started the working group on the
national health information
infrastructure and didn't have in fact
in that model either education or
research and so it's a map couple to
some extent but the fact is we need a
more robust model i think to be thinking
about this more recently i think the
office the National Coordinator
struggling a lot of important things was
continuing to do that as well and of
course I think there have been enough
activity from the privacy stronger
advocacy side and the some of the mental
health community that have offset the
fact that the researchers have not
really come out of the woodwork on this
I got a lot of things that's not going
to mount worrying about and they really
haven't particularly stood up
sufficiently I to to balance it out
balance it and as Madison also noted
nothing
so it's contagious opinion especially
especially on questions which means
acceptable very different glosses we get
in the mind and distress of itself and I
think we've seen some of that there have
been concerns we're a very egregious
lapse in a specific place has been
generalized and seemed like well this is
must mean it's all going haywire yeah
exactly and so again that's hardly new
to our time so I anyway the thing that
I'm really positing here is I think we
really do need both policies and
standards that do try to you in a free
society allow us to better manage to
these things without saying that privacy
isn't really important so the question
is how do we enable this and I think to
a few minutes I think we need a new
model on the standard sign and I think
we also need to have a few new policies
that in some instance could be federal
and summons this could be state this
will be available I think in fact
there's number of people I guess they're
watching this elsewhere now and it will
be available to go down through this but
the point is today we don't have a
single consent process to allow citizens
to share their personal data if they say
look I'm interested in public good you
know at age 70 what I got to hide or
worry about particularly I'm willing to
take the gamble you can use my data and
put my name on it so that's just fine
with me and I'm willing to take whatever
downside is that my compliment you don't
want to do it no that'd do it but
allowed to do it and and rather than
having to an institution by institution
by program by program Brett program
actually have ways to facilitate access
as well as obviously for those who don't
want to do that not do it so I think the
point is is that in a lot of these areas
it's not like what we've done is wrong I
just think it's not quite unbalanced and
it so for now though this is going
nowhere this unique identifier thing
right now is going absolutely nowhere in
the water at the federal level and I
think the point is is it my
argument would be that why couldn't you
allow the citizen to choose an
alphanumeric number and allow them have
a site that's done and also as you'll
see relate to this I read this book
nudge I don't know if you read that but
it's interesting i think point that if
you're in the cognitive psychology area
if you could just nudge people little
ways it doesn't really cheat a lot and
it frankly make society better makes
everybody in a better situation they use
the term libertarian paternalism as i
already said we have paternalistic
policy today but we don't have
offsetting paternalistic policy at the
same time so anyway the reality today is
that we really don't have a proposal for
action to allow you know informed
consent across the broader kinds of
scale for legitimate IRB research you
could do it based on IRB approved
research and I think we do know that
obviously talk about the genome and so
forth I mean this is a time when
obviously these are not trivial kinds of
questions for human health and disease
so I think we have a question here
that's real and also it's not like the
citizens and the people we're putting a
lot of billions of dollars in the
research destination in the states in
some way so the point is there's a lot
of sense with for example about 38
billion going to our own national health
information IT infrastructure for
electronic records and such so we
clearly want this but we don't
necessarily have it balances as we might
so what I'm personally advocating and
I've talked to a few states I'd like to
see I have on my driver's license in
Virginia a little heart i can say i'm
willing to see my organs used for
transplant of my age is probably my
cornea innocence about all that
benderson it but the point is that i'd
like to see a few other icons there that
if there's a not a slice in route you
can use my driver's license number as a
unique health identifier and if there's
not a slash through it you can pass my
data around among health professionals
have a website so dachshunds
institutions could check and see where i
was on
I have another one a little microscope
saying you can use my data for IRB
research and I'd like to have in some
states an option once you say if I call
or send an email to you if there's a
protocol it comes up that comes that
might apply to me or my family you'll
push it in for me you'll push that to me
so I can maybe sign up for participating
and then the last one would be a little
DNA spiral they would say you can use my
genetic information thing now I would
totally change the picture of things I
think it's totally consistent with a
free society probably the state level is
the best way to do it instead of federal
frankly because they are currently our
main ID is our state driver's license
and the transfer the organ donation
thing is something to public certainly
familiar with but I'd prefer to see it
actually as a mandated thing you had to
choose one or the other at the time you
got your your license but in addition
what I what I'd like to do is have some
pilots we're like it confuses do not
resuscitate well whatever i'm not i'm
not here to advertise the icons i think
that that's a good point we need to
figure out with with certainly after the
death panel been alone all that business
we probably ought to talk through those
things but some kind of simple thing
what I'm saying it would have some
credence I mean who's using a microscope
particularly today either but but is you
need some icon that might work and
that's part of why pilots would be smart
to too soon I obviously have user groups
that would look at some of this so we
could look at opt-in opt-out mandated
choice and so forth so anyway I'm
talking about this I'm on Bob cons
national corporation research
initiatives on his board now and I think
we've been talking about some ways to
deal with the keeping those data secure
and that kind of a pro CH and obviously
it'd be nice if you know Washington
State want to be a partner in that
clearly they do a lot of research anyway
I probably had too many slides in this
deck but I really do appreciate the
you need to come and i'll be interested
both now as well as later on feedback
you might have literally in any
direction I've been added long enough
that there's no such thing as
unimportant feedback and and that would
be great so thanks again for the
invitation I don't know if you're
interested but if you are interested in
annual symposium it's bill in November
not too far from here so anyway thanks
very much thanks again hey when a while
back my credit card was compromised I
got a new number and you caught in the
made two days later try that the Social
Security numbers and think what happens
if somebody from Virginia move moves to
Maryland god forbid and until think of
Hannah social security numbers as well
as and keep a credit card company I have
my dogs so maybe they'd subcontractor
Microsoft to do it so one of the things
that would be interesting is I thought
about medical records as in who owns
medical records today I don't know as I
look at my my credit report and all this
other stuff information is stored about
me is not owned by me and I have no
control over whether they use it for the
bank's user for research they have all
the credit card records and they use it
to profile me and do lots of stuff has
there been any thought that says you
know we should really make medical
records owned by the individual and if
you have a test you have whatever you've
got them available to you and then you
could go and participate in studies and
you could then give your your
information now you do that individually
one at a time where you can put it into
a repository than made it available to
things like this well that in fact the
Congress did recently passed something
along that line and I think it's
terrible law personally I'll tell you
why this is from my perspective it says
that basically if you don't want any
data to go into your record and you pay
for it rather than the insurer getting
information then it doesn't need to be
in your record and what I don't like
about that is that oh ok so if I'm poor
and I don't have the money to be able to
do that I have absolutely no choice I
mean I just think it's not good long you
know so for my
perspective there find the law different
I would have done that you're saying i
have to pay well that's what the that's
what the Congress has done on that you
can opt out but you have to pay the
freight if you're going to opt out but
the point I'm making is is it's
basically regressive it's very
regressive and so I'm not saying you're
advocating that but I'm just saying
that's the closest thing we've tried
today to have a way of letting people
protect their their information now the
other concern of course on that too is
as a clinician if I then subsequently am
taking care of a patient who's decided
to not have this information in their
record and I prescribe a drug that
absolutely would be counter indicated
based on if I knew that information as
the government going to protect me from
you know abusing if you will making a
bad malpractice because obviously the
person's done it so I think this is this
is another dimension of social good is
really really critical and I think
there's a lot we have a chat room
american college of medical informatics
we had a lot of buzz on this issue and
an hour feeling frankly and at least
it's not a policy but of the sort of
their minds is that we really need to
make sure that if people choose that
take that route they realize exactly
what they're exposing them to it's much
more serious than they might on the
surface think that it is that they're
just sort of interesting that they can
have a cake and eat it too necessarily
and and because i don't think in fact
chronic congress is likely to to give
you that kind of malpractice coverage if
you will so there's a lot so then the
question is well if some bike chooses to
act that way would you decide to just
say look you need to find another care
provider i'm just not willing to take
care of you under those circumstances
it's too it's too problematic for me as
a caregiver I think the laws you
described it is
a totally worthless thing right then so
that's not what i was saying where you
can pick and choose what goes into your
record well but that's currently the
others I understood I appreciate that
but I'm sorry I'm proposing an
alternative there there really is you
know fine you guys the insurance company
has the record as well but no matter
what goes into it I get a copy on it
historically historically look at the
data ownership historically an
institution and the clinician of on the
record and in fact actually when a
physician changes that practice he sells
oftentimes his records to the next
provider that's coming in so it's not
it's not a clean this is mine and if you
will for all time and so forth it's
actually in fact we just did a couple of
studies a couple of policy projects that
the talking about secondary health data
when we did the IOM study in 91 we sort
of said if it's involved in care itself
it was considered primary health day and
all other uses were considered secondary
we recently said look we really don't we
should avoid this issue of ownership
because frankly leads to just a lot of
discussion and not good public policy
instead what we should talk about is
what is good what are good stewardship
principles for anybody that's going to
have access to person specific health
information and what are really in fact
the way you treat these data and and in
fact with a fair amount of both both
kind of moral guidance as well as
obviously some legal constraints as well
because and so in other words secondary
data as we ultimately defined it was
only those data which are being sold to
somebody without any conceivable
possible benefit back to me I'm not
being paid for they're not likely to be
any good coming back to me from that we
now say that you probably ought to
consider secondary data but otherwise to
run a health care system and look at
quality and and in fact actually arrow
HIPAA one basically sort of said well
business operations quality payment and
so forth is is is a part of care that's
basically what how they defined it so
they basically even sort of define
it that way and then they're trying to
kind of tighten up some of that and with
the personal health records how do you
look at other kinds of associates that
might see some of those data and put
some of those protections whether in
fact they say look we don't need it
we're good guys and gals or not yes sir
i'll be happy to stick around too if we
extrapolate from some rigid data was a
wild extrapolation the fake phone call
some charlatan claiming to be a doctor
and saying he has a mr. Decker in front
unconscious and breathing funny to
happen roughly twice a minute in the US
though it let's go it's a big country
numbers are rose amazon online little in
NH area you guys to take that offline
and discussion okay
it's my question in this day seems like
there are two issues that are almost or
tunnel but in your presentation they
were very tightly to leave identity and
privacy and then some level there are
some I don't need
see one helps the other so why is it so
critical to just I think that's just
where the policy dialogue is kind of
worked out I think you're right i mean
how some of these things necessarily get
into the same bed doesn't necessarily
have that an entrance if i'm tracking on
your question i don't know but if it
gets into the policy debate then it's in
the debate and you get to deal with it
or whether it kind of makes sense or not
evidence around different models at
other countries yeah oh yeah sure but
obviously I didn't have time to get it i
mean when i was in the UK i was actually
party to some of the discussions in fact
i was a member of the Knuffle trust and
we had a policy meeting one night and
Lord Hunt who was the under secretary
for health at that time as we were
discussing this he says well now that
you mentioned that you know this is a
serious problem right now I got a
committee that's looking at this and so
normally we would break for a nice
dinner and instead of breaking for
dinner and laying ago we went back into
session and then tried to give him some
advice and I'll leave it at that but the
point I'm making is yes this has been
certainly and I think some countries
have done a much better job and and some
of its actually because of the
importance that the biomedical research
industry is to the nation's economy it's
not like there aren't economic
dimensions of what we're talking about
to and in fact I think that's that also
is an issue here that I didn't even talk
about it all 4°c
some smaller countries decided getting a
comparative advantage from having the
right kind of policy family right if
they had the Austral backing and public
consensus well clearly you look at you
look at stem cell research I mean
obviously that's the most recent example
of mean this is a global market you look
at medical tourism to Bangkok and again
we priced an awful lot of people on to a
spot market internationally and it's not
a trivial issue they're all board
certified in American Medical
Specialties so it's not like they're not
well trained the hospitals are very good
and so that yeah there's no question we
are in in fact a global kind of market
there's also opportunity unfortunately
as well though for abuses in some
countries and exporting people so from
my perspective again I think it's part
of why I'd like to see us deal with this
better is that I think the fact is the
world does pay some attention to what we
do at the margin and if we had better
policy I think everybody could benefit
from that as well so it's a little bit
of selfishness in that context him
anyway thank you very much again for the
invitation